we've selected 10 tips to help you get
ready to launch your news app and start
gaining readers as effectively as
possible
one test on real devices and identify
early issues your readers are consuming
your news on a whole range of
smartphones and tablets so it's
important to test with as many Android
devices as possible in order to flag and
fix any issues the pre-launch report in
the Google Play Developer console
identifies crashes and displays issues
and security vulnerabilities the report
is powered by firebase test lab and is
generated every time you upload and
publish an alpha or beta apk you can
also use a firebase test lab paid
offering if you want to run customized
testing across a wide range of devices
even the ones that are hard to come by
to run alpha and beta tests a new app or
update that readers love gets good
ratings and reviews that help drive more
downloads by sharing your app with
readers through alpha or beta tests you
can gather feedback on potential issues
without affecting the apps public
ratings and reviews you can then fix any
issues before the public release a great
way to build your beta user community
and engage your loyal readers is to
invite people who've left your review in
the Play Store by sharing the signup URL
3 release your updates in stages
we know you have a large audience and
your brand integrity matters Google
plays staged rollouts helped to catch
any outstanding issues not found during
testing by progressively rolling out
updates to a small percentage of readers
this means if you catch any issues you
can halt the rollout for reply to
reviews newsreaders can be quite vocal
use this to your advantage to build
loyalty and engage your audience app
reviews often contain valuable feedback
and suggestions for improving your app
so read them regularly replying to
reviews engages your readers when you
respond to negative reviews try and
indicate how and when you will address
the feedback moreover you can take
advantage of the review analysis reports
in the developer console to see how
users review your app in relation to
specific categories the two reports
benchmarks and topics analyze how each
topic impacts your overall app rating 5
monitor your crash reports Google Play
collates information about your app and
makes it available in the Google Play
Developer console if your app crashes
you'll be able to see why and fix the
issue quickly you can also use firebase
crash reporting 6 run experiments on
your store listing when users open your
apps listing they'll almost instantly
decide if your app meets their needs
unique icons a short to the point
description and good quality relevant
images showing your news homepage and
articles but grab their attention you
can use store listing experiments to
help find the best combination of these
elements
seven drive over-the-air installs from
your site sign readers in with Google on
your website then offer the option to
install your app over-the-air in the
Google Play Developer console create a
project and register your website and
app clients add the app installation
prompt to your website sign-in eight
link users straight into your native app
with app links users following web links
on devices are frequently presented with
confusing choices tapping a link often
results in the system asking the user
which app should handle that link use
the app link extension to ensure that
deep links open in your app use also the
chrome native app install banner on your
news website so that readers who don't
have your app installed and are directed
to your website from a share can easily
install your app 9 optimize for word of
mouth growth with firebase invites word
of mouth is one of the most effective
ways of getting users to install your
app use firebase invites to make it
simple for your readers to send content
to their friends over both SMS and email
it ensures that referral codes recipe
entries or other shared content gets
passed along with the invitation no
cutting and pasting required 10 get your
app in Google search
having your apps content included in
search results exposes it to a huge
potential audience use app indexing to
surface your branded apps install button
in search results and make it easy for
readers to acquire your app head over to
Google Play Developer console to start
taking advantage of these features if
you want more tips on how to improve
your news apps and build a better mobile
business check out the other videos in
this series and download the news
publishers playbook
you